[Música]
bienvenidos al año 112 después del
convite vaya que ha sido un inicio de
década muy complicado para todos a
principios del 2020 todos tenemos muchos
proyectos que iniciar tareas que
entregar vacaciones a donde ir
que completar y tuvimos que suspender
todo
en marzo del 2020 la organización
mundial de la salud dictaminó que
existía una pandemia por kobe 19 y el
mundo se debió de detener
especialmente aquellas organizaciones
que dependen de una alta e intensa
interacción social para funcionar como
el sector educativo lo vimos en la
necesidad de trasladar nuestras clases
presenciales al modo virtual de la noche
a la mañana esto por supuesto sacó a
flote un montón de problemas
estructurales pero también grandes áreas
de oportunidad y es justamente eso de lo
que quiero hablar el día de hoy con
ustedes sobre la brecha digital y la
inclusión en tiempos de la pandemia
vamos con lo primero la brecha digital
la brecha digital se refiere a esa
distancia que se va creando entre las
personas que tienen acceso a la
tecnología y los que no y
desafortunadamente cada vez se va
haciendo más grande y durante la
pandemia la hemos observado aún más no
es algo nuevo de hecho desde que empezó
a haber un mayor acceso a internet
empezamos a ver este fenómeno con mayor
frecuencia
no es exclusivo de países en vías de
desarrollo de hecho es muy notorio como
por ejemplo en las áreas urbanas frente
a las áreas rurales existe una gran
disparidad en el acceso e inclusive
dentro de las mismas zonas urbanas
dependiendo de tu extracto
socioeconómico puede ser que tú esté
rodeado de antenas de celular y al no
tener los medios para poderte conectar
lo mismo daría que estuvieras en un
desierto la penetración de internet
ciertamente es alta al día de hoy
incluyendo en países como méjico sin
embargo no es para nada universal de
hecho en el 2019 la unión internacional
de telecomunicaciones dependiente de la
onu dijo que más de la mitad de la
población mundial no tenía acceso a
internet esto fue en el 2019 hace antes
del comicio
ha habido muchos proyectos para tratar
de reducir esta brecha digital por
ejemplo a principios del 2000 hubo una
una fundación que ya no existe de una
laptop por cada niño donde a través de
esta fundación se diseñaron y se
regalaron a niños en situación
vulnerable equipo de cómputo
en méxico durante a mediados de la
década pasada el proyecto de méxico
conectado intentó dar una cobertura a
internet en todo el país creando nodos
en cada población
y recientemente el proyecto luna de
google trata de hacer algo similar pero
utiliza globos aerostáticos que se
posicionan sobre zonas de muy alto muy
alta marginación y de difícil acceso
para proveer de internet todo esto ha
sido muy bueno y son esfuerzos muy
loables pero no ha sido suficiente
nosotros como universidad no solamente
tenemos que lidiar con la falta de
acceso de internet sino también cómo le
podemos proveer a nuestros alumnos de un
medio viable para poder aprovechar todas
las clases ciertamente la mayoría de la
población estudiantil en el mundo ya
cuenta con un equipo de supercómputo en
su bolsillo el cual es ideal para
coordinar tu agenda social para tomar
fotografías oír música jugar pero no
para tomar todo su curso todos los
cursos en él es muy complicado además
hay que considerar que al menos en
países en vías de desarrollo la mayoría
de nuestros estudiantes hacen uso de
internet móvil a través de sistemas de
prepago entonces en una videoconferencia
todos el gigabyte
aparecen tenemos que buscar la manera de
proveerles este acceso ahora no
solamente se trata del software y de
hardware también tenemos que repensar la
manera de cómo damos clase es es muy
curioso los que somos profesores durante
el año pasado aprendimos lo difícil que
es dar clase a través de una cámara web
y en ese instante también tuvimos que
reorganizarnos reinventarnos ver que
funcionaba prueba y error todo con la
finalidad de otorgar una mejor calidad a
nuestros estudiantes y los estudiantes
también tuvieron que desaprender para
aprender a aprender en este nuevo
esquema virtual
ahora los planes de estudios los
programas las clases tienen que ser
rediseñadas bajo este nuevo contexto
para promover el autoaprendizaje el
autodescubrimiento y se deben de proveer
suficientes herramientas de
retroalimentación para que los alumnos
independientemente de su acceso se
sientan integrados integración e
inclusión este es el otro tema que yo
quisiera tratar con ustedes
una de las muchas lecciones que nos ha
dado la pandemia es lo democrático que
es el confinamiento los que hemos tenido
la fortuna de quedarnos en casa
encerrados hemos experimentado las
mismas victorias y frustraciones al
momento de lidiar con la tecnología para
poder dar clase
esto también ha generado algo que yo
nunca había observado de forma tan
tangible un sentimiento de empatía
realmente nos ha sensibilizado frente a
todos los que están en las mismas
circunstancias que nosotros
y eso me puso a pensar sobre este
fenómeno de que justamente en este
período de encierro es la primera vez
que todos podemos tomar la misma clase
en ciertas condiciones de igualdad
siempre y cuando tengas acceso a
internet no importa tu grado de
movilidad física no importa tu clase
socioeconómica no importa tu identidad
sexual todos recibimos la misma
educación esto a mí se me hace
fascinante y yo creo que es un tema que
vamos a estar estudiando por los años
los años adelante de nosotros
ahora
las universidades ya de por sí trabajan
con presupuestos muy estrechos en
particular en países en vías de
desarrollo
y soñar con dar una educación para todos
aquellos que quieren entrar a nuestra
universidad frecuentemente es un sueño
imposible de alcanzar
bueno la pandemia nos ha enseñado que es
posible que con los medios tecnológicos
con los que ya contamos y siendo
creativos realmente podemos dar una
cobertura mayor
no quisiera soslayar el gran dolor que
la pandemia por kobe 19 ha provocado
para todos todos en el mundo millones de
familias han perdido seres queridos
tan solo en nuestro país hemos perdido
el equivalente en población a una ciudad
media esto es es terrible sin embargo
también hemos descubierto que las
organizaciones como las universidades
son muy residentes tienen un alto grado
de adaptabilidad
en el reto e inventan soluciones
creativas para poder lidiar con él y
aprender de él
yo creo que cuando lleguemos a la udc la
universidad después del comité vamos a
llegar fortalecidos las universidades el
día de mañana no solamente deben de
aprovechar todos los avances
tecnológicos que han ocurrido en este
año y medio
debemos de aprender también que bajo
cualquier plataforma debemos de promover
los sentimientos de empatía de inclusión
debemos de dar a la sociedad
algo a cambio por todo lo que nos da
primordialmente creando día a día vita
beat mejores humanos muchas gracias por
su atención